>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> David Plylar: Good evening
everybody, my name is David Plylar
and I'm a music specialist in the
concert office at the music division
of Library of Congress and
it's my great pleasure tonight
to welcome you to our
special lecture,
our guest speaker is the
distinguished [inaudible] professor
of music at Princeton
University, Kofi Agawu.
Prof. Agawu has taught at major
institutions around the world,
from the University of
Ghana, Hong Kong University,
King's College London and Yale
University to pick just one each
from four continents among others.
Prof. Agawu is an author of five
books and lectures on topics ranging
from music analysis of
numerous musics to tonality
as a colonizing force,
excuse me in African music.
His books demonstrate a phenomenal
breadth of scholarly inquiry,
in his first book Playing With
Science A Symbiotic Interpretation
Of Classical Music Dr. Agawu
explores the expressive
and structural aspects of classical
music by composers like Haydn,
Mozart and Beethoven in a discussion
of possible semiotic meetings.
Excuse me.
His second book, African Rhythm
Of Northern Ewe Perspective,
takes a more holistic approach
to the study of rhythm grounded
in language and broader
cultural contributions
to rhythmic expression.
Prof. Agawu's third
book was the first
that I encountered
representing African music,
Postcolonial Notes
Queries Positions.
Here he shifts the focus
from subject to scholar
and confronts the study and critique
of African music's raising
important questions about the way
in which we think and
talk about music.
His next book continues to work
he began in playing with science,
Music Is Discourse Semiotic
Adventures And Romantic Music.
It shows Dr. Agawu's unique
approach to dealing with questions
of musical meaning
in romantic music.
Prof. Agawu's latest
book from which the topic
of this evenings lecture is drawn
is The African Imagination In Music.
Please join me in welcoming
Kofi Agawu.
[ Applause ]
>> Kofi Agawu: Thank you
We're just getting set up here
so it'll be an hour or so.
Okay, so it's an honor to have been
invited to speak here of the Library
of Congress this evening, I'd
like to thank David Plylar
for this kind invitation and for
arranging things so expertly.
The book I've been asked to talk
about, the African Imagination
In Music is an introduction to black
African music published last year
by Oxford University press, here
is what I say on the opening page
of the introduction quote.
"In its richness and diversity
Africa music remains one
of the most vital repertories
performed today.
It's history reaches back
into the ancient times,
its continued cultivation
on the continent is as alive
and human centered as it ever was,
and its worldwide influence
is indeed subtle and profound.
This book is designed to
support exploration of some
of the core features
of African music,
for the most part emphasis is
placed on the music itself rather
than on external factors,"
end of that quote,
and if you sense anything polemical
at all about that introduction
or you're sensing some
of that is real.
So my approach is not to sell
you facts or alternative facts
about African music but
to find creative ways
of supporting your
own exploration of it.
I'm not seeking to do Africa
from scratch, complete with maps
and photos nor do I wish to peddle
Africa to its historical oppressors,
I aim or about to reach readers
who'd like to listen to Africa music
and for whom a modest elaboration
of its core features
might deepen appreciation.
What do I mean by African music?
African music is music conceived,
created and performed at least
in the first instance
by African peoples.
It includes vast repatries
of precolonial origins,
we call that traditional music,
others of more recent vintage
associated with a populist sphere,
we call that popular music, and
still others produced in of mold
of arts composed music art,
we call them art music.
My book focuses on traditional
music but includes examples
of popular and art music.
So let me just start of by
playing you an example of the kind
of traditional music
that I write about,
this is a southern Ewe
dance called Agbadza.
[ Music ]
That's not Agbadza.
Okay, this is going to be a very
long evening if you're just going
to sit and not move in any way
to this music, it's impossible
to just sit and listen quietly.
Okay, so my book has 8 chapters
and I just want to start
by saying a few words about each
of them so that you get a sense
of the project as a whole,
after that I'll focus
on the fourth chapter
which deals with rhythm.
So chapter one, Music
And In Society,
explores the uncommonly close
connection between music
and society, reminding
us that music is a part
of society not apart from it.
I identified 3 important
occasions for musicmaking as work,
ritual and entertainment.
I discussed the role of music in the
lifecycle with particular reference
to death, and I end the chapter
with reflections of the nature
of the relationship between musical
structure and social structure
and in particular the
role of circles
in various conceptualizations
of music's social attachments.
Chapter 2 On Musical Instruments
acknowledges the incredible number
of sound producing objects
found on the African continent.
There's been a great deal of
research on musical instruments
and since part of my aim in
the book is to introduce some
of the scholarship as well I cite
a handful of writings by 18th
and 19th century explorers.
Now there's a famous classification
system devised by two Germans
on the eve of the first war,
on Bostol [phonetics] and Zacks
which is a mainstay of
scholarship on African music.
So it specifies, I don't know,
some of you might know it.
It specifies things like aerophones
which are wind instruments,
chordophones, string
instruments, idiophones,
self sounding instruments
and membranophones drums.
I reject this classification
system and suggest instead
that we pay attention
to indigenous ideas
about musical instruments
including their names
and number of which onomatopoeic.
It is better to say dum dum
than to say talking drum.
The chapter ends with commentary on
individual instruments like voice,
hand clap, drum and so on and
on ensembles especially those
that cultivate heterogeneous
sound ideal.
Chapter 3 which is my personal
favorite explores what I believe is
a deep and profound relationship
between language and music.
I suggest that you will get
a lot more out of listening
to Africa music if you know African
languages or are at least alert
to the imprints of language as
both sound and sense on music.
The topic is huge so I
focus on just six subtopics.
First the relationship between
speech tones and melody and this
because as you know many
indigenous African languages are
tone languages.
Second, talking drums that
is rendering speech on drums
or mimicking the rendition
of speech on drums,
it's the second level pretend
talking drum if you like.
Third song which is an amalgam
of word and tone and those
of you who'd think I'm old-fashioned
will find a discussion here
of a hip life song by Omanhene
Pozo a Ghanaian rapper.
Chapter, then the fourth
thing is meta-language
which is language about language.
The fifth is idiophones
or picture words,
the Germans call it cloud's
builder, these are marked words
that vividly depicts
sensory perception
and it's a linguistic phenomenon
that has a musical dimension.
And finally a certain linguistic
residue in performance sensibility,
is one of those things where,
I think there's something there
but I can't really nail it down and
so I put it there as a suggestion.
Chapter four is about Rhythm
which I will return to,
chapter five makes a case for Melody
because African music surprisingly
is not normally credited
with great melodic imagination.
One scholar says that "melody is
not one of the essential features
of African traditional
music", while another,
a very distinguished
one writes I quote
"rhythmic interest often compensates
for the absence of melody
or the lack of melodic
sophistication",
this is actually a textbook but I
will not mention the author's name.
These claims ought
to be interrogated
and not accepted on face value.
So by way of a counter
assertion I analyze a few songs,
an Akah entertainment song, a
lullaby [foreign language] a song
by Fella, and an Ewe dirge to show
that if you approach melody as
and meaningful utterance then the
idea that there're any deficits
in Africa melodic imagination
becomes frankly unintelligible.
Chapter six discusses form, another
of those domains was elaboration
by African musicians has
not garnered much praise
but all you have to do is pay
close attention to the ingenuity
with which performers
deployed techniques like call
and response variation form and
even moments form to see how nuanced
to this aspect of Africa
music can be.
I end the chapter with a suggestion
that many African forms
are strategically partial,
that is to say they incorporate
holes HOLES not phantom WHOLES.
You see if you have a music
that is implicated in society,
it's traces will always require
completion outside the narrow
confines of the music itself.
Chapter 7 deals with harmony,
forms of simultaneous doing,
singing together, playing
together and I explore varieties
of parallelism like singing in
parallel thirds or parallel fourths,
parallel fifths in different
performing practices.
I also touch on modality and
inevitably on the influence
of European functional harmony,
mostly it's Handel and Mendelson.
The book ends with a
chapter on Appropriation,
we all know that African
music has gone global
that it is regularly appropriated
by musicians around the world,
musicians in the popular music
business as well as composes
of art music like Steve
Rise [phonetics].
What are the ethics and aesthetics
of such acts of appropriation?
I suggest the terms in which
such questions might be answered
and I conclude by acknowledging
the work
of Africa's own arts music composers
in this case two Nigerian
composers Joshua Ozoigbe [phonetics]
and Fred O [phonetics].
So these are some of the topics
covered in the African imagination
in music for a mere $27.95
you can explore them further
if you are so inclined.
So let me turn now to my main
task this evening which is to talk
about rhythm, I'm going to read you
parts of the four, play you a number
of recorded examples, and then we
can have a discussion afterwards.
So the Rhythmic Imagination
In African Music.
By common consent rhythm
is the distinctive element
in African music, "if European
music is specially marked
by the rich variety of its forms
and the splendor of its harmonies,
African music is similarly marked
by the fascination of its rhythms,
Africans have not merely
cultivated their sense
of rhythm far beyond ours
but must have started
with a superior sense of rhythm".
This has to be a British
writer, right?
"says WF Ward" Here's one from
[inaudible] who's well known
as a conductor, scholar of jazz
composer and so on "in respect
to rhythm, African music is
unquestionably the world's most
complex music."
And finally here's a colorful
one from a book review,
the book is A.M Jones's magnum
opus, it's a book called Studies
in Africa Music it's from
1959, it's a newer book by now.
The review is by a chap who was
actually a missionary to Nigeria
in the 1950s and 60s
"Jones's book introduces us
into a strange enchanted world of
pure sound made up almost entirely
of complex patterns
of drum and gong taps
to call these complex is an
understatement, the very thought
of them makes one dizzy, imagine
two drummers playing together
and cross rhythm, three against two,
now stagger them so that they're
out of phase, now add two
other drummers and a singer
and clap accompliments all
rhythmically at cross purposes
and out of phase with one another.
And I was actually tempted to
play you that Agbadza example
but that's the kind of thing
that he was thinking about.
So now the reviewer's dual
invocation of the mystical
and the technical, the mystical
being a strange enchanted world
of pure sound and the
technical being three
against two cross rhythm, this dual
invocation I would say book ends the
thematic content of the larger
discourse on African rhythm
and there're many stages in between.
If you want more of
these quotations,
they're kind of entertaining you
can look them up in my earlier book,
the one called Representing
African Music which David mentioned.
Now despite such wide
widespread affirmation,
rhythm remains a contested topic
in African musical research, why?
Well, for one thing scholars bring a
variety of disciplinary backgrounds
so psychology, aesthetics, religion,
phenomenalogy, mathematics,
music theory, musicology,
ethnomusicology and so on.
While this could in
principle be enriching,
it has also spawned a
proliferation of terminology
that does not always promote good
understanding, we encounter temps
like metrical inversion,
conmetric accents as opposed
to contra metric accents, poly
meter, multimeter, African 44,
simultaneous multidimensionality
and so I like that one
because there are so many syllables.
There is an unproductive
excess here, I think.
Second, scholars disagree
about the nature
of the actual organizing principles
and how best to represent them,
is there a pulse of the beats and
if so, are they equidistantly placed
and can they be grouped into
meters like 4 4 and 12 8?
Is there a one, what is an accent,
what about the so-called
master drummer,
how does he come up
with his patterns?
And these are not rhetorical
questions by the way,
they can be and have been answered.
The real issue is why they keep
coming, you know, coming up.
Third, to make matters worse,
there's not even a word
in many indigenous African languages
for rhythm, you could not go to eleo
or a yuroba or an Ewe drummer and
say "I'd like to discuss the subject
of rhythm with you, mate."
Fourth, understanding
rhythm seems to me
to demand a performative stance
not normally required of analysts
of pitch for tumber or texture,
rhythm after all is movement,
it embraces the general time
aspects of music, it is felt,
it is sensed, it is heard.
So without the mediation of
performance I think the gap
between the phenomenon and its
representation grows and fifth
and finally Africa is huge.
Over 1 billion people as
you know, 2000+ languages,
2000 ethnic groups, 54
countries and so on.
While some have suggested that West
and Central Africa are the elaborate
rhythm areas as distinct from east
and southern Africa what are
the elaborate polyphony areas
that generalization is
already problematic.
Indeed it seems unlikely that there
exists a single rhythmic practice
given the extraordinary
variety of expressive modes some
of which have resulted from
sedimentation's of style
through trade and migration and
from influences both across Africa
and between it and other
regions of the world.
These amounts to big
challenges for anyone attempting
to characterize the scope
of the rhythmic imagination
in a short lecture.
So let me set idealism aside,
I always find it convenient
to do that, and do what's
doable in the 30 minutes
or so that I have left and I'm just
going to identify four principles,
or concept that I consider
fundamental
to African rhythmic expression.
First is the distinction between
rhythms of speech and rhythms
of the body, second is polyrhythm,
third is the so-called
timeline pattern,
and fourth are the master
drummer's rhythmic narratives.
So my interest here is
in the foundations rather
than their decorative
exterior, the base if you
like rather than the superstructure.
I suggest that the complexity
of African rhythm the so-called
complexity is an orderly
and rational complexity not
the outcome of happenstance
or a vaguely defined
improvisory [phonetics] process.
By attending to its structural
aspects through analysis,
we can appreciate better the
real intellectual achievements
of African musicians.
So first rhythms of speech
and rhythms of the body.
So the world of rhythm
is made up of two kinds,
rhythms of speech,
and rhythms the body.
Rhythms of speech are that
gyrational, accentual,
and periodic patterns
that result from speech
in everyday verbal communication,
syllabic durations alternate
between long and short,
accentual patterns emerge either
from phenomenal stress
associated with timbre
or from tonal change
while periodicity is says
in the asymmetrical successional
segments of performed speech.
Be it a greeting, the swearing of an
oath, a town crier's announcement,
the pouring of libation,
the minister's sermon,
a radio announcer's interview,
the Chiefs linguists admonition,
or a traditional healers
incantations.
The rhythms of spoken language
may be reproduced directly
in a speech mode of
instrumental performance
or incorporated into song.
Rhythms of the body are showcased in
the scores of dances performed daily
across the continent [inaudible]
in Uganda, Kpanlogo in Ghana,
Nganda in Gambia, [inaudible] in
Cameroun, Sindimba [phonetics]
in Tanzania, [inaudible]
in Nigeria and so on.
These repetitive rhythms enable,
motivate or accompany movements,
whereas rhythms of the body are
modes of communal expression,
rhythms of speech are modes
of individual expression,
whenever speech takes on
a mode of communality,
it submits to regulation and
is molded into poetry or song.
The rhythms of the body then act
closer to music than to speech
because their purpose is
to carve time in response
to movements while rhythms
of the body have the capacity
to communicate verbal messages,
their primary purpose is
to make play possible.
Now distinguishing the
rhythms of speech from those
of the body allows us to
present their conjunction
as a basic syntactical
unit in African performers.
A favorite organizational device is
the succession speech mode followed
by song mode where song may
include dance which serves
as the external form
for many genres.
Here's an example from the Ewe dirge
repetition and I should just say
by the way I don't intend anything
funny by singing for you tonight.
So [singing in foreign language],
so [foreign language] is
a pretend sympathizer,
somebody who is pretending
to be sympathizing with you,
but is actually laughing
at you behind your back.
[ Singing in Foreign Language ]
It's like speech, right?
You can basically
[ Singing Continues ]
So free rhythm if you
like, speech rhythm,
it's declamatory rhythm,
it's on its way to song.
Now this lower material may be
played on a drum or a xylophone
or a flute or some other
instrument and it's often valued
for its contemplative
or philosophical import.
Proverbs, deep thoughts and
an enigma's put performance
and listeners in mind of
those things that lie beyond,
powers that exceeds their
own and this in order
to underline the solemnity
and spirituality
of the performance occasion.
Only after this acknowledgment has
been made do the performers proceed
to a second main section are
the section featuring rhythms
of the body.
So this dirge Afakwei
[phonetics] continues
with a call and response pattern.
[ Singing ]
You see you didn't do it.
Anyway, now we're now in the realm
of strict rhythm, metrical rhythm,
gentle movements accompany
this second part of the dirge
as befits their status
as elements of a genre
of crying songs [foreign language].
I don't have time really to
pursue this model further,
it's common in many traditional, in
your traditional forms but I want
to turn now to polyrhythm which
many consider the quintessential
manifestation of rhythms
of the body.
So rhythms of the body
are typically elicited
by an ensemble producing
distinct rhythms formed
into a polyrhythmic constellation.
While there is no single ensemble
that obtains throughout Africa,
the idea of an ensemble delivering
a highly coordinated musical message
refracted through a set
of contrasting tumblers
is the standard.
Whether it's a large ensemble
like a thirty piece Mozambique
xylophone orchestra or a small one
like a four piece like
Yuroba [inaudible] ensemble,
whether it is made up of
the same instrument type
or different instruments the
ensemble as a collective intends one
and only one thing, namely to
create the conditions of possibility
for shared meta rhythmic expression
around a common point
of temporal reference.
Now you all know what polyrhythm
is so let's prove it tonight
by doing a little exercise
and I'm going to just ask you
to speak the constituent
rhythms of a southern Ewe dance,
this is a Gahu [phonetics]
dance in the version
that David Locke has taught us.
So if I could just have the first
three rows to my right, yeah?
So we're just dividing it here and
you're the bell so you're just going
to go gon, gon, gon, gon,
gon, gon gon, gon, gon,
just choose any pitch
you want, gon, gon,
gon and the compliment
here you're the rattle,
gon gon, please keep going.
It's going to be a
long night, I know.
Pati pati pati papa, pati pati
pati papa, pati pati pati papa,
pati pati pati papa,
pati pati pati pa.
So starting with you
Emefa and folks,
the last three rows,
so let's start again.
Gon gon, gon, gon, gon,
gon, gon gon, gon, gon.
Pati pati pati papa, pati pati pati
papa, pati pati pati pa cata, cata,
cata, cata, cata, cata,
cata, don't be late
cata, cata, cata, cata, cata, cata,
last line, dentonton, dentonton,
dentonton, dentonton,
dentonton, dentonton.
Raise the level dentonton,
dentonton,
and listen to the others
[inaudible sounds], very good.
David, can you help me here?
Okay, so I'm just going to play you
a recording to make you feel bad
of what you just performed.
[inaudible], ah okay.
[ Music ]
That was you, the bell,
that was you.
Very good, huh?
You're better.
[ Drumming and Singing ]
Okay, so goes on, yeah?
So polyrhythm manifests
a many in one ethos,
it is a form of simultaneous
doing rather than uniform doing,
its effectiveness derives in
part from the different shapes
of the component rhythms,
the non-coincidence of points
of instantiation and termination
and extensive often unvaried
repetition of the patterns.
And again there many many
polyrhythmic ensembles I won't be
able to illustrate all of
them but you did very well.
So what kind of ecology
sustains the cultivation
of this prominent musical device?
Plurality, yeah?
The plurality enshrined
in polyrhythmic playing
or singing is a disciplined
plurality.
Each player maintains the
integrity of his part while
at the same time ensuring
the coordination
of the ensemble as a whole.
This is an impressive ability
cultivated that over many centuries,
this kind of polyrhythm is not
for weak minds although superficial
acquaintance may lead one to suppose
that the ensemble is
a loose configuration
in which individuals
do their own thing,
correct performance is
typically constrained
by a central point of reference.
One that is always felt but
not necessarily sounded,
that is why we speak of polyrhythm,
many rhythms not poly meter,
many meters or many
points of reference.
Then deep connection to dance,
the most profound response
to polyrhythmic drumming, as
the example you just heard
and performed is found in the dance,
well I'm not going ro ask you to do
that tonight, watch the dancers
and in particular the feet
and you will see how these
rhythms are embodied.
A good dancer distills the
metrical essence of the music
and expresses it in movement,
the body grounds the
apparent diversities
of timbres and onsets patterns.
Dance conveys a synoptic sense
of locus of beat and weight.
The music is translated, interpreted
and at the same time
generated by the dancer.
So if as is sometimes said
in the beginning was rhythm,
then dance was not too far
behind, and here I'd to say shame
on all those 19th-century Christian
missionaries to West Africa
who told the converts that it
was a sin to dance and indeed
that their dancers were evil.
Don't worry, my father
was a minister
so I'm allowed to say these things.
The idea of polyrhythm has
occasionally elicited some rather
fanciful associations.
Here is John Collins expeciating on
what he calls the poly sided life
"relativism and pluralism
permeate many aspects
of traditional African life, things
must come and be done in multiples,
no single rhythm deity or
timescale should steal the show,
African music is polyphonal
[phonetics],
their religions are polytheistic,
their calendars polycyclic,
the plastic arts poly angled
and their social organization
polycentric.
You can almost fill in
for me when I come to it.
This poly sided African
view even applies
to traditional domestic life,
marriage is customarily polygamous
just as no single rhythm is allowed
to dominate the African beats
so two no single deity, soul,
or timescale is allowed
to hog all the limelight
of the African ritual cosmos" You
know I almost didn't read you this
quote because I was very worried
that it'll be the only thing you
remember from my lecture tonight.
I'm not sure, this is me now, I'm
not sure that this has been taught
through sufficiently, are
these analogies or homologies
or simply systems supporting
similarly structural rhythms,
but Collins is not the
only one seduced by polies,
here is BB Bakari [phonetics]
Yusif's quote,
"although a contemporary
Nigerian society
and contemporary Yuroba culture
is on the surface divided in terms
of Christian and Islamic
faiths, the deep structure
of the society is polytheistic
and ordered by the spirit world
of the accommodative
traditional gods,
this theological background
is revealed most readily
in aesthetic practices
such as dance and music,
polytheism in spirit translates
into the aesthetics of polyrhythm"
but if, sorry, ahead
of myself there.
But if polyrhythm is normally
constrained at some sort
of background level, the level
of deep structure then surface
plurality should always be
understood in relation to
subsurface singularity.
Bakari Yusif's wish to reject
conceptual monotheism is
understandable but here
argument is somewhat inconvenient
by the existence of an
ineliminable mono somewhere
at the back of ensemble playing.
Moreover explanations such as
Collin's and Bakara Yusif's
that seek to align processes from
different domains; from religion,
architectural, linguistics, biology,
sociology and so on must contend
with the possibility
that discontinuities
between domains have just as strong
claims to nomativity as continuity.
Timelines.
So now with the sound of
polyrhythm ringing in your ears,
I'd like to just zero in
on one of its components
on the so-called timeline
pattern and observe
in a little bit more technical
detail, I hope you'll grant me that,
some of the workings of
the rhythmic imagination.
Now anyone who's listened to any
of the varieties of African music,
being it traditional,
neo traditional
or popular is probably already
familiar with timelines.
So what is a timeline?
A timeline is a rhythmic pattern
of modest length that is repeated
in a manner of austinato [phonetics]
throughout a particular dance
drumming, yeah?
So if I do the one
that you guys did.
[ Drumming and Singing ]
You could be doing that for
a hundreds of times as long
as the dance is lasting
but that's a timeline.
Another one very common one is;
[ Drumming and Singing ]
That one is the 221 2221 pattern.
Do you know how I got that?
Those are just the gyrations, yeah?
Okay, normally entrusted to
the bell or custonet or sticks
or stone timelines often
project a distinct perhaps even
memorable shape.
Although there are bells and sticks
made up of unchanging pulsation,
the majority of timelines display at
least two contrasting node values,
a long and a short if you like,
this by the way is another sign
of the minimalist impulse that's
widespread in African creativity.
Although the function of timeline
patterns is sometimes likened
to that of a metronome, there's
a significant difference.
Unlike metronomes which mark time
and thus help to locate patterns
against a wall of accentless
strikes, timelines carve time,
they are integral to the music.
Each individual timeline is in
principle structurally dependent
on prior metronomic foundation.
There's a lot to say
about timelines,
about the historical origins,
their geocultural distribution
and their association with speakers
of Bantu languages who're
also exponents of polyrhythm
but I'm going to for go all of
that in the interest of time.
In my book you'll find a
discussion of 12 of these timelines
out of possibly hundreds
from West and Central Africa,
but I'll only talk about
four of them tonight and the,
let me just say that
the structural features
that I think are worth noting are:
first inter onset interval
structure, which I said 221 2221,
that just means the distance
between onsets, yeah?
Second is the meter, is
it 12 8 4 4 and so on.
Third is a possible notated
mnemonic and fourth is the grouping
with the thing, it's grouping
So I'm going to do this
as a little oral exercise
with you, yeah?
So let me start off with
the archetypal clap pattern
which is [clapping]
now when I'm doing this
and you're sitting there
looking at me, it feels weird.
That's all, I know
it's an imposition.
Okay, what's the inter onset
interval pattern there?
Sorry? Well three shorts and
two longs, right [clapping]?
So it's 222 333, yeah?
You okay with that?
Very good.
So I'm going play you
some examples of this
and I'll explain why I think it's
an archetypal pattern actually
because it combines
twos with threes,
it has a generative capacity.
Once you have two and
three you're okay for a lot
of Africa rhythm by the way.
So let me just play you
some instantiations of this.
In fact the Agbadza
that I played you
at the beginning has
that clap pattern.
[ Music and Clapping ]
Okay, good, very good Now it
doesn't always come in that form,
here is another instantiation
[music],
this is from Liberia,
the first one was Ghana.
Let's go to the Central
Africa Republic,
this is a little more motivic
[music] I think it's cool,
same thing 222 333.
Here is another one if
you're still in doubt.
[ Music ]
You have to hold on, so
once those drums come in.
So that's one timeline
and if you want to pursue
that through a whole host of
repertories, you'll find it there.
Here is another one, this one is the
so called standard
pattern, it goes like this.
[ Clapping and Singing ]
So the interval set
pattern is 221 2221, yeah?
So this is one of the
best-known of all timelines,
I'll play you a couple of examples,
here is just the timeline
by itself on there.
[ Music ]
if I asked you what the beat was,
you probably wouldn't know it,
it just keeps going,
shorts and long, yeah?
But here it is in a way
that makes the beat.
[ Music ]
If you're still in doubt, let's
go to Nigerian, no Benin actually
and do some Bata drumming.
[ Drumming ]
Okay and if you're
operating on a budget,
here is one on a bottle for you.
[ Drumming ]
From Liberia, no reflection
on the economy there.
So the standard pattern has a
number of interesting properties,
it retains a high degree of
invariance under rotation,
this is all music theory speak,
but I know you're ready for it.
It has a maximally even
distribution of those seven onsets
within the 12's span and that is
to say it samples the space evenly.
It is isomorphic with respect
to the interval structure
of the diatonic scale, the scale
that you guys use [singing]
if you take the interval
structure is 221-2221, okay?
Don't get too excited about that.
And then for us mortals,
it will be enough
to observe the patterns never ending
or never settling down quality,
this is just speaking
metaphorically,
not metaphorically I just
mean it is kind of latent,
it is perpetually forward-looking
as if endowed with a permanent
and acoustic feeling and when
it is danced to by Ewe dancers,
the operative reference point
is four dotted quarter notes
in a 12 8 meter.
So [singing] that's the
underlying beat structure.
The third one, this one I think will
be familiar to you because it is the
so called [inaudible] of
afro cuban music [singing].
It's normally done in 4 4, has
a very clear shape in the form
of the mini beginning, a middle
and an ending, its groupings
and metrical structures are
aligned and it may be related
to the standard pattern through
a process a person calls analog
transformation, again I
won't want to go into that.
It has five onsets within this
sixteen pulse of four beat span
and I'll play you a few
examples of, oh before I do
that I'll just play you one more
example of the standard pattern
from arts music this is
an [inaudible] by Fred O.
[ Music ]
I left that one out, that's
the standard pattern, 221 2221,
and let's go to the clave, clave
is 334 24 and here is an example.
[ Music ]
I feel like I'm complaining
because I'm playing all
these Ghanaian examples,
let's go to the Cote D'voire.
[ Music ]
Let's go to the DRC.
These are all women, you
could tell right, yeah?
And so on, yeah?
So what is, one of
the interesting things
about this particular timeline
is that, are you ready for this?
There are 4368 possible rhythms with
five onsets from among 16 pulses.
I wish I could say
I came up with that
but it's only a mathematician
who's working things out and put,
in other words if you imagine
16 pulses and you're going
to do five onsets anyhow
4368 possibilities.
So it would be interesting to find
out why African musicians and some
of their relatives abroad have
chosen this particular arrangement
and forsaken almost all others.
Godfred Toussiant who is a
mathematician who's been writing
about the geometry of rhythm has
answers to this and other questions
so instead of giving you
the answers I'll have you go
by his book, anyway TOUSSAINT.
And then one more timeline
I wanted to put this one
in as a cool timeline and
you'll see what I mean
because it is done
on it at water drum.
[ Music ]
So they just, they've cuffed their
hands [inaudible] that's all,
could be, I could play
you many more of these
but I think you get the
point about timeline,
the nature of the timeline,
the properties, I like to think
of timelines as pearls of
African musical wisdom.
Although they're part of the
ordinary unmarked musical language
of many African communities,
experienced in everyday genres
of song and dance, they are
also extraordinary in the extent
to which the pack in poetry, the
extent to which the pack in poetry,
they pack in tight organization
and characteristic profiles.
Ultimately, these timelines
will have to be returned
to the polyrhythmic textures
to which they belong in order
for their full significance
to be grasped.
And just to say a few things
about the so-called lead
drum or the master drum.
So the West African drum ensemble
often features a lead drummer
or master drummer who enacts
various rhythmic narratives.
Now those who are enamored
of big men may well associate
the master drummer's role
with a characteristic complexity
of African rhythm, but I have dwelt
in this talk on more modest roles
because I believe the foundations
are not always properly understood.
Still, I think it would be perverse
if I did not say a few things
about the lead drummer's art.
So all I'm going to do here
is play you three themes
from an Akan dance called "Adowa"
in Willy Anku's digitalized version
which will show how the
master drum elaborates
or develops its themes, okay.
So here is theme 1.
[ Music ]
Okay so that's the theme.
Now, let's hear what the master
drummer actually does with it.
[ Music ]
Thank you.
All right, so here is theme B.
[ Music ]
Okay, and then theme C.
Okay, so a seasoned lead
drummer arrives at the scene
of performance armed with knowledge
of procedures to be deployed
in the course of whatever
dance he is beating.
In Adowa which we just listen to,
a typical performance would feature
a succession of thematic areas
and the space between different
theme areas would be occupied
by a conventional bridge passage.
Within each area, a verbally-based
thematic pattern is subjected
to motivic elaboration.
How long the drama
dwells in a given area,
which specific devices he employs,
will depend on the dynamics
of his interaction
with dancers, his mood,
his sense of the location and so on.
Now, it is in the specific
technical manipulation
of the grouping structure
of individual themes
that the sophistication of the lead
drummer is evident Working with sets
of 12 and always aware
of the position
of the ostinato bell pattern,
the drama devices patterns whose
spans sometimes equal 12 8 notes,
sometimes exceed it or
sometimes fall short of it.
Anku calls these sets, supersets,
and subsets respectively;
they behave in just the
ways you would expect.
If a pattern introduced by the
lead drummer exceeds the 12th span,
he carries forward the surplus.
If the pattern is a
subset of the 12th span,
he knows that a compensatory
gesture will be forthcoming
and whether pattern is perfectly
aligned with the rating 12,
no credits or debits
are carried forward.
In this way, the performance
proceeds logically
and in full awareness of
the shifting relationship
between bell and lead drum.
The result is a deep level
of coherence that may come
as a surprise to those who may have
underestimated African intellection
or indeed, disappoint those
who would prefer mystical
or affective explanation
to a rational one.
Now, it bears emphasizing,
that lead drumming
and ensemble playing take
place within aural cultures.
No traditional lead drummer worth
his salt plays from charts or scores
or notation, so all of
the modulo 12 arithmetic
that Anku describes takes place in
the heads of drummers not on paper.
Paper rhythms answer
to different orders.
Indeed, they can reach
heights of complexity unheard
of in musical aural tradition.
Aurality, au all right?
Aurality enforces a regime
in which shape, placement,
and presentational vividness
dictate the basis of play.
The vibrant life of African
rhythm derives precisely
from this incredible
awareness of the aural
and choreographic potentialities
of its constituent patterns.
And so just to close, this
is a little parting example.
In 1965 Simha Arom and Genevieve
Tourelle published a recording
of the music of the Ba-Benzele,
one of the so-called pygmy groups
of Central Africa which included a
little flute tune labeled, Hindewhu.
In 1973, Herbie Hancock in a
signature album fusing jazz
and funk, appropriated this tune for
his own remake of Watermelon Man.
You probably all know the story
because it's been told quite
a few times I buy Steve Feld,
Steve Pon [assumed spelling] among
others and that is the Bill Summers
who was Hancock's drummer, imitated
the Hindewhu sound on a beer bottle.
So here first, is the Hindewhu.
[ Music ]
Okay. Now, listen to what
Herbie Hancock has done with it.
[ Music ]
I had to wait for that moment with
the bass guitar before I stopped it.
So what Herbie Hancock has done,
not only is the metrical
multiplicity gone,
a jungle atmosphere has been created
to enhance the exotic
effect of the appropriation.
In effect, if you like, a new
rhythmic regime has been imposed.
Now, Herbie Hancock is
entirely within his rights
to appropriate this idiom of
African music and to incorporate it
into his own language
as he sees fit,
so questions of propriety
are not my concern here.
My concern rather, is with a
purely musical transformation.
If the shapes of African rhythm
that we've been exploring
today are anything to go by,
complete with their
silence, or short down beats,
their symmetry disrupting kinks,
their nonalignment between grouping
and meter and so on, then Hancock's
appropriation imposes as I said,
a new rhythmic regime perhaps and
this is only gently hyperbolic,
it represents a form of
metrical colonization.
There is an overall
change away from subtlety
and a hierarchized
multiplicity to overtness
and singularity, hegemony
if you like.
The winks and knowing smiles
had gone, on difference.
So although African music
has often been portrayed
as being radically different
from Western music based
on an entirely different principles,
Horn Bussell wrote in 1928,
and more recently one of her
colleagues down in the South, wrote,
"A different way of
being in the world."
There is essentially, that is to say
at a certain level of abstraction,
no difference between the organizing
principles of African rhythm
and those of Western rhythm,
both sets of repertories features
speech rhythms, a palpable tactics,
symmetrical as well as
asymmetrical rhythmic phrases,
superior beats and groups of beats.
Periodicity is governed
by processes distributed
across multiple dimensions, degrees
of polyrhythm, and the interplay
between pre-composed
and improvised material.
African rhythm indeed manifests the
same kind of hierarchic patterning
that one finds in Western music.
Namely, an elaborate surface held
in place by a simpler subsurface,
a foreground subtending
a background.
What differences there
are, stem from idiomatic
and aesthetic choices made
by individual communities
for particular genres and locations.
For example, it is not that Western
music lacks offbeat patterns,
if you know Beethoven you
know that cannot be true.
It is rather that some
African music,
especially drum-base repertoires
that have acquired symbolic status
as exemplars of authentic
African music, invests heavily
in persistent offbeat patterning.
It is not that African
music lacks down beats,
it is rather that some African music
takes the weight off the down beats
in order to create a more
fluid or mobile process.
It is not that Western instrumental
music is not the dependent
on language, it is rather that the
speech mode in instrumental music
of the 18th and the 19th centuries
for example has been obscured
I think in the writings
of theorists with different agendas.
Comparisons like these
can seem nave
or counterintuitive especially
for people for whom the sound
of African music is self-evidently
different from that of Western,
but peering beneath the surface
to behold the specific
organizational procedures,
will reveal a significant degree
of subsurface convergence.
Western and African rhythm share
patterns of well-formedness.
It is in thematizing than
well-formed that preferences,
some of them marked, are exercised.
The African rhythmic genius
is best appreciated not
from separatist accounts postulating
radically different foundations
and premises but from comparative
studies showing how African
musicians excel at
the things we all do.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> If you have any
questions, please let us know
and we'll give you a microphone.
Not all at once.
>> Hi, you spoke about language
influencing the rhythms,
could you speak some
different African languages
to show us examples of that.
>> Yeah, so for example, the
Adowa, the one that I played you,
the theme, see if I
can find, oh this one.
[ Music ]
What the drummer is saying is "Tome
ku me, menie, tome ku me, adanpa.
Tome ku menie."
I'm not a Twi speaker but, buy me
and kill me, "menie" this is me.
So that's an example of a rhythmic
pattern that has a verbal component.
Now, so it's a slightly more
complicated issue than that
because although this is
research that was done by Anku,
we're lacking historical work
on these sorts of patterns
so it is not clear whether in
fact, the verbal component came
after the rhythm had been devised.
Now you know that sometimes
people playing
in orchestras say will put words
on a sudden rhythmic pattern
to make it easy for them
to play that rhythm,
but we need to know whether "Tome ku
me" was the origin of this pattern
but that's one example in which
the language is aligned with it.
But the entire phenomenon of
talking drums is precisely that.
That's what talking drums do.
If I say, "Mema mo atenase,
nana ne mpanyinfo," he palyed
on the drum, [mimics drum playing].
You know, whatever it is you know.
"Asuo twa okwan, okwan twa asuo,
opanyin ne hwan" [mimics
drum playing]?
There's nobody explaining it to you,
you're just hearing it on the drums
and you're supposed
to know what it means.
[ Inaudible question ]
In that case, in that particular
case the language is being
reproduced, yeah, absolutely
but you know,
if you follow that if you like,
derivational process you'll see
that it's not always a
straightforward thing because even
within talking drumming,
they're waiting patterns,
for example waiting signals, you
know, and very soon you will see
that what started as
something lexical, you know,
with a semantic component
actually begins to lose some
of that in a musical situation.
So it's a huge, I talk a little bit
about this in the fourth chapter
of my book about, sorry, in third
chapter, the chapter on language
and music which I said
was my favorites
but yeah, that's how it works.
I think that the language sediment
is something that can be elusive
and it doesn't because you know,
these are languages
that are now mediated.
If you put people a language
or some linguistic utterance
in a musical context, there is
something else claiming your
attention, right, so it would not be
correct as one of my students wrote
in her final but I still passed
her the other time, to say,
"Anyone who can speak an African
language can understand the talking
drum," you see, that's
a freshman talking.
It's on the right track but it's
a little simplified, you know,
because the talking drum
language itself is already
in a very compressed
universe, you know.
Oh how many lexical items?
Nketiah says there are 500 words
in the Akan you know, lexicon,
we're talking about 500 words and
you think about your spoken language
and how many you have you
see, so you're already dealing
with a restricted universe.
Which then, sorry, you didn't
ask me about talking drums.
Yeah, but you wanted to know
about how language
influences rhythmic patterns.
[ Inaudible question ]
Yeah, well, I've two responses
on what you just asked.
Absolutely, that's what I've heard.
I'm not a pattern expert,
but the relationship
between international patterns
and spoken international patterns
and melody for example, in
Hungarian, is very strong
and that certainly parallels what
you find in the African continent,
but here is the issue, Africa has
conservatively 2500 languages.
Why are we not spending more
time with these languages?
Why are we not, sorry,
now I'm beginning to sound
like I'm chastising
you for something.
There is a wealth there that
we're not talking about.
So I guess my response is that no,
I don't think that the issue is
different in kind from the example
that you brought but I do lament the
fact that for a continent so rich,
you know, in the linguistic
sphere, you know,
I see so many people you know,
who are you know, they're there,
some are abroad or you know,
semester abroad and they're hanging
out with other people who are
speaking English, you know,
they don't want to
learn a little Yoruba,
it'll you do you a lot of good.
And when I said that if
you know African languages,
it will enhance your
appreciation of African music,
I mean that there will be certain
terms, there is a certain sort
of contours for example, that you
will immediately recognize as things
that come from the spoken language.
It's a mannerism, it's a
sensibility, they're very subtle
but they're no less
important, you know.
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah, there's a supplement
there that,
but these things need
to be studied I think.
That's really, all I'm saying.
As you know from the remarks
with which I close my lecture,
I think we should unburden Africa
of difference, in other words,
you know, people will say "Well,
but that happens everywhere,
that what we all do so, well so you
mean we shouldn't talk about it?"
No, we will keep talking about
it because if you burden Africa
of difference, then you're saying
the only things worth talking
about as far as Africa is concerned
is that which is different.
So you don't want to talk about
the regular flute but you talk
about a nose flute, you
know, that can't be right
and this is what the
literature for the most part,
I may be exaggerating, but this
is what the literature is saying,
burdening you so that, that
which seems like it's shared, no,
no we don't want to hear that.
But that one is different, you
know, what kind of life is that?
>> In your book, is
there a guide as to
where one might find audio examples
to follow the analysis in the book?
>> Yes, so here's the thing, I'm
glad that you asked me that question
because one of the things about
the book is that I referred
to many recordings of African music.
Alan Lomax said famously I
think, it was already in the 50s
that Africa is the best
recorded continent.
You know, it will come to
you as a surprise but I mean,
there are masses of recordings.
Why are we not using
those recordings?
Because there is a
scholarly sect that at least
at a certain point discouraged
you from using those recordings
as a basis of any kind of research.
You have to go in there,
make your own recordings,
get those mosquito bites,
you know, and come back.
You can't sit here and be an
armchair person and cheat,
so this incredible resource
has been sitting there.
Some of them are commercially
available, some of them
and especially nowadays my
students go on Spotify or something,
they subscribe to this and they
tell me they found lots of things
so close to the beginning of my
book, there is a list of 100 CDs
and I don't mean this
trivially, I just say you know,
if you listen to these 100 CDs,
you'll have a pretty good
idea what African music,
mostly traditional music,
is about and my students set
about listening some of them and
discovering many of them, you know.
So there is also at
companion website
to the book that has a few examples.
Those are the ones that I talk
about in some detail
in the book and places.
So if you have a copy of the book
you'll get a code that tells you
where to go to find those
but many of the recordings
that I referred to, you know, you'll
find them in a standard library.
In the old days we we're doing
LPs and then the CDs came along
and the entire record
shut and then you know,
but these things are about.
So yeah, I'm glad you asked me about
that and I should make it clear
that yes, a lot of what I referred
to is in the recorded you know,
the literature of recorded music
and there are footnotes in the book
that will tell you where
particular things are.
It's nothing obscure; I think
we should share our texts.
>> I had a question.
You didn't mention that I
heard any Senegalese music
but that's the African music I'm
most familiar with and that's
of course just a little bit.
The bones or the, and they do
a lot of talking drums as well.
Can you speak on, I don't
know what you call the bones
that they use to drum with.
Yes, but I thought well,
they call them bones I think.
>> Yes, so I'm afraid no,
I cannot speak specifically
to Senegalese music, I know a little
bit about it but it's not, you know,
and I actually hadn't heard that
they refer to those sticks as bones,
although I can say that there
are traditions as one in Nigeria
where they drum with bones and they
claim that these are, you know,
bones of people they you
know, okay, you know,
but yeah so there is actually
an interesting article,
I forgot now the author's
name but these kinds
of intimidation tactics
are there lot.
You know, you will see like the
northern area, we have a big drum
and you'll see at the top of
drum is a drum called Adabatram
and you'll see these gorge-like you
know, things you know, draped with,
they're all covered with a
cloth but if you ask them,
they'll say they're skulls you know,
some of us think they're
calabashes but that's okay.
But that's meant to tell you that
you don't mess with these guys
because look at the skulls
on a drum that they're using.
But this pattern of, and
I'm not saying, I mean,
they may well have started off as
skulls, they may well be skulls,
I don't know because you cannot see
these things with the naked eye,
but these are the sorts of patterns
that happen I think in any you know,
kind of social system, you
have to build up your own sort
of symbolic capital, ways in which
you are going to showcase things,
ways in which you are going
to intimidate, you know,
your competitors and so on and
that's just a very normal thing
as you know from living
today in Washington DC.
So, sorry, were you...?
>> Yeah, I have a question about
the lexical items that you refer
to in response to a question earlier
and you talked a bit in the chapter
and then the talk about the
importance of understanding language
to understand what's going
on, and I'm wondering
if you have any insights into the
making of traditional music today
by musicians who may have
a different relationship
to traditional languages
than what's had in the past.
Whether it's because young musicians
today are learning English primarily
in addition to only to
speak to their parent
in traditional languages or for any
other reason that their relationship
to traditional languages and
meaning behind them might affect
their [inaudible].
>> Yeah, no, that's
an excellent question.
So the other week, one, sorry I
keep talking about my students,
I live with them, I work
with them, so retiring.
The other week, one of my students,
we were talking about tone languages
and she said, this is a student who
speaks, I won't mention the country
but comes from a country and speaks
a tone language, she said you know,
I didn't know until I took this
course that I was a speaker,
she is 19 years old, that I
speak a tone language, you know.
This was news to her that okay, I
had to confess, yes so it's the Twi.
The Twi that she was
speaking is a tone language.
Because once she was alerted
to how differential pitch can make a
difference to meaning, she realized,
"Oh I've been doing
this all my life."
I suppose it be like prose, what is
that thing about message or down,
whatever it is, not knowing
what they've been speaking all
their lives.
So that is the happening and as
you say, a lot of young people
who have maybe a slightly
different, in some cases,
a more tenuous relationship
to language and to the way
that language features
in traditional music.
I don't think one wants to
be legalistic about this,
because the nature
of these influence,
I mean all you can do is wish,
you know, wish that many more
of these young people would
speak these languages,
understand them better, and
still have a better appreciation.
But having said that, they're
also doing interesting things
in a way they know how to, you know.
There are mixtures now
and of course if we got
into the whole popular music realm,
there you'll see whether you think
of it as a cosmopolitan spirit or
whatever it is, it's coming together
in some very interesting,
very creative ways.
I still lament, you know,
the fact that there is a kind
of linguistic sediment that is
lost and all I can do is lament it.
I can't really say, you know,
that means everything is
bad or anything like that.
I do think though, and this is sort
of from an African nationalist point
of view, but I do think that
if we move the goalposts
to privileged people who do
actually speak these languages,
maybe we could win a few victories
over our historical oppressors
but maybe that's a little
too trivial for you.
So yeah, I think what
you're pointing
to is a very real phenomenon
and I don't know
that I have a straightforward you
know, answer to how to deal with it.
There's somebody at the back, yeah.
>> You talked about Watermelon
Man sampling, I'm not sure,
sampling, what it was but...
>> Hindewhu.
>> Okay, I was wondering whether
you know of African music,
simply non-African music and whether
the nature of African music allows
that accommodation to happen
like how well can it
integrate non-African music?
>> Yeah, again that's
an issue that comes up.
I myself have not pursued it,
I think probably for more,
for ideological reasons,
that is to say
that people ask me all this time,
what about African appropriations
of other music, you know?
Yeah, there are people who
are interested in, you know,
are you appropriating I don't
know, James Brown or Elvis
or you know what that mean
and so the reason I just have
a little trouble with it is
that the historical situation, you
know, you can't trivialize the way
that power, you know, has
flown in the sort of historic
and in other words,
basically if I start singing,
what is it that the Kenyan
girls were singing, you know,
"Three blind mice, three blind
mice, see how they run," you know,
and I'm doing it in a funny way
and you are not seeing the tragedy
of that but rather
what you're seeing is
that I am also speaking back,
you know, here I'm speaking back
because I'm taking your
tune and I'm modifying it.
That's kind of a joke
to me, I'm sorry,
I get very upset about
this, you know.
That is not to deny agency, but it's
to downplay an underlying condition
you know, that I don't see how
that can be put aside so
it is difficult for me
to wrap my head around that.
I'm acknowledging that there's
creativity at all levels
so don't misunderstand
what I'm saying,
I didn't answer your question
because you wanted real examples
of this kind or something.
I know that there are people who do
that kind of work but I just think
that there is a kind
of problem with it,
with the kind of assumption
that underlies it.
That's really the frustration
I'm expressing
and I'm sorry I got
sort of caught up.
So no answer to your question
but it gave me a chance to...
Yes.
>> I really appreciate
the last two questions
because that was what I
wanted to ask and also,
I appreciate just everything you
spoke on today and your chapter 8
that you talked about,
this appropriation piece really
intrigued me and especially
when you mentioned the quote
where you were saying this could
be a hyperbole in terms of,
I can't remember how you phrased it
but like imposing this
structural kind
of colonialism to its original beat.
And I'm a migration scholar, I
migrated from Kenya, I grew up here
but I have very much African
nationalist parents and what I fell
after hearing everyone
asking questions
and you speaking back is almost
a theme in terms of as scholars
of African or anything African, we
just want to be heard and we want
to show that our work is important.
I don't know if you feel
that way but I'm curious
to know how you see your work in
the larger context not just in music
but in terms of promoting African
culture, promoting African legacy,
and I don't know if you
think of it that way
but I'm just curious
to hear your thoughts.
>> I think some of that will
be for other people to decide.
I think I want to get it
right, whatever it is,
so if I write something,
I want to get it right,
it's really the main concern, follow
whatever the scholarly protocol is.
Yeah in idle moments of course, it's
possible to talk about these things
and you know, but I don't know that
I am, sorry I'm just stammering here
because I'm not quite sure how
to answer that bigger question
about you know, the
larger scheme of things.
The world is huge you know,
I happen to work in music
which is a very small field, you
know, it's not like literary studies
or anthropology and so on,
bigger fields [inaudible]
but it's a small field.
It's a field with some sort
of technical requirements also
that sometimes if you're
drawn to those, discourage you
from seeking certain kinds
of publicity for example,
when you get into technical
detail, you know, about say a dirge,
which I do in the book unashamedly
and I will continue
doing that, you know.
People say oh why are
you doing that?
Do the people think
that way, you know?
That's not what I'm about,
I'm saying let's see what kind
of insight comes from thinking
about it this way you know,
and then you can decide what to do,
but if you think everything
originates and do you think
that when you say that
people think that way,
that their thinking is static?
You know, that somehow their
thinking doesn't evolve,
there's a lot of silly things
that people say, you know,
basically to discourage certain
kinds of honest inquiry, you know,
and to the extent that I'm
above anything is simply
to say I think these things
are worth talking about openly.
You can decide what you want to do.
I mean, when I told you
don't get too excited
about this parallelism between, the
isomorphism between diatonic scale
and this, and so it's like wait
so God gave the Africans rhythm,
you know so they have their 221221
and then gave the Europeans pitch,
you know, so they are the 221221
so we know the Europeans don't
have any rhythm, right, and so on
but then, I don't like
the other one,
then we know that Africans don't
have pitch, no I don't like that one
because we have some
amazing you know,
approaches to pitch organization.
But if more of us I think would just
get these things right, you know,
and then let the ideological
things take shape.
It's not something I spend very
much time thinking about but thanks
for asking it because maybe I will
think a little bit more about it.
>> Thanks so much for your talk.
Who are your favorite musicians
and what musical instruments
do you play well?
I'm sure you play all of them
but which ones did you
concentrate on in your studies.
>> Who are my favorite musicians?
I don't know that I could
answer that, really, honestly...
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah, that's if I mention
one now, the problem is not
with the one I mention but
the ones I don't know mention.
>> Well make it [inaudible].
>> No, it's going to take
too long and I grew up,
well at a certain point when I
was sort of actively in music,
I thought I was going
to be a composer,
that I was composing mostly, yeah.
[ Inaudible ]
Notes...[laughs] and silences.
Well, very early on I was
writing lots of choral music.
As a minister's son, you
don't have a choice there
and things could be done.
I was writing things for my
school, we had a school orchestra,
I wrote little pieces
with...you know,
that's where African rhythms thrown
in but well always modulating
to the dominant and
that sort of thing.
As an undergraduate, I was a
composition major essentially,
but I got to a point where I
realized that what I was hearing
and writing was already out of date.
So my friends and my peers who were
winning all the competition prizes
where writing things that
I knew they didn't hear.
I could not write something that
I didn't hear because I thought
that was a lie and so the idea that
you could just explore in this way,
you know, it's not like
you ask one of them,"
So who are you writing this for?
Or what are your writing it for?
Or we're writing it to win a
prize or something like that,"
whereas I was very constrained
in the way that I was brought up.
You're writing this for, that you
know, it's an anthem for Christmas
or you know, [inaudible]
but it's all very modest
and so I didn't have
the kind of if you like,
freedom which other people had.
It's mixed in with other things
and I know we don't want to get
into you know, compositional
ethics and so on.
David you'll probably have
a lot to say about that
so that's anyway, that's that.
Every once in a while I bring
out some of the things I wrote
when I was 18 or 19 and say, "hey,
that one isn't bad," I actually
but no, I mean, and
also by the way, I mean,
composition can be
a means to an end.
So for me the year spent
composing were years alerting me
to certain ways of
appreciating what composers do.
So that's why I think you know,
musicology students for example,
should be forced to compose
because at the end of the day,
they probably won't write some of
the things they're writing today
if they understood music
more from the inside,
and if they took this
more sympathetic approach
to what a composer does.
So that's what it all led to
for me in the end but I would,
to the extent that there's anything
that I was say sort of was useful
to me, it was that
compositional path but a lot
of what I do now is
analytical and orientation.
I like to think that it's in
sync with some of the ways
in which composers think.
[ Inaudible ]
You said well and the answer
is none, [laughs], none well.
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah, somebody has
betrayed me but [laughs].
>> One last question.
>> I just want to follow
up on a couple
of questions that have been asked.
I take issue with the maybe the
slightly negative connotation
of the Herbie Hancock
appropriation just personally;
I'm not make an argument but...
I see maybe it's an homage that
takes us from the starting point,
just something new with it,
but my question to you is,
in your perspective, how should one
best take this African polyrhythmic
heritage and create with
it while still honoring it?
>> Yeah, I wish I have the
answer to that question.
I did write a whole chapter on
appropriation and at one point,
I said maybe the question of
appropriation is moot and it's moot
after all because we are all, if
you like trapped into these sort
of inter-textual spaces you know, to
compose is to recompose, you know,
how are you going to stand outside
the things that you remember,
the things that you know you
learned, and so on, in order to say,
okay this is mine but this
one is not mine and so on.
So I think there's
something very problematic
about the idea of appropriation.
However, there are degrees of
appropriation but that's one thing.
There are traditions that are based
on, somebody asked me about sampling
for example, where the compositional
method actually is premised
on sampling things, you know.
A lot of the hip life now that we
find coming out of Ghana, you know,
these kids are sampling old you
know, like supposal that example
that I mentioned so
there is old highlife
and then there's what I'm doing
now which is all those rap stuff,
we're bringing old and new together
and so on in this overt sampling
if you like, in this
overt appropriation.
I do think that there are
some political sides to this
that my task really was to air the
issues and then let people talk
about things from you know,
whichever angle they
find appropriate.
So for example, Steve Reich, a lot
of people talk about Steve Reich
because as you know, he had a deep
interest not only in African music
by the way, in Indonesian music,
in Indian music but he you know,
went to Ghana in 1970 or
thereabout, studied some music,
actually most of that time,
I think he had malaria
so he was ill [laughs] but you know,
we have ways of dealing
with these people.
But his work is influenced
by African music.
Sometimes they are of a quotational
sort, you know, so taking a timeline
like in clapping music or you
know, I don't know, there you know,
and he said, "What I wanted
to do was to think African
but not to sound African."
To think African, that is you know,
to internalize that way of thinking
but to speak my own musical language
because he said that's
what he wanted to do.
You know, composers say all kinds
of interesting things,
sometimes very poetic.
I don't know how you are able
to finally test whether he achieved
his aim and so on, you know,
but that's not for me to say.
Ligeti is another one,
interesting case where in the book,
Martin Scherzinger whom you
mentioned has actually done some
interesting work on this.
He actually went and spent
some time in Basel looking
at Ligeti's sketches and he found
that you know, how you know,
people keep like shopping
this on their sketch
in the corners and so on.
Ligeti had all of the stuff that he
was reading from various journals
on African music, he was
fascinated by this stuff.
Does Ligeti's music sound African?
Not to my ears, I've
never heard anything
that I would say it's conformative
with the repertoires that I know,
you know, he had a deep interest,
he pursued it but in the end,
all of this was if you like,
domesticated within his
particular idiolect, you know.
I think Scherzinger in writing
that article thought he was
exposing Ligeti in a way,
you know he doesn't
quite put it as crudely,
he's a very sophisticated
thinker, but for us, you know,
who are not as sophisticated,
we see him saying you
see you thought this is
like your avant-garde and pulls
up but let me show you how much
of a debt to Africa there is and
it's not on the surface of the music
but we have to go and
look at these sketches,
these private biographical
note in order to expose this.
When all of that is done, you know,
whatever you read, whether you stood
on your head three times before you
wrote this with journals you read
and so on, you write a piece
and people decide they like it
or they don't like it, you know.
So really, it would be inappropriate
for one thing for me or I think
for maybe, well, certainly for me,
to be offering any prescriptions
about how you deal
with these things.
I do think however that, a good
understanding of the phenomenon
so a good understanding of
polyrhythmic to me is useful,
and what you do with it
if you're a composer.
Are you a composer?
>> Oh no.
>> Okay.
>> I'm a drummer, player...
>> Yeah, because you got the
metrical thing in the Hindehwu,
which is good, very impressive.
Anyway, so yeah that's, I mean,
I've gone on at length but that's
where I'm coming so the chapter
on appropriation is not you know,
pointing fingers at these bad guys.
There is a piece by David Fanshawe
which some of you may have heard,
maybe it was done in high schools
in a song called African Sanctus.
It's a piece from the 70s and the
Kyrie of that piece has a call
to prayer, an Arabic call to
prayer and then there's a sort
of renaissance-type polyphony that
he composes on top of it, you know.
If you read what the composer
says, he says I'm trying
to bring together these two faiths.
I'm trying to show that the
Christian faith you know,
and the Muslim faith
you know, can coexist.
That's his idealization
but if you're, you know,
a kind of mischievous
hermeneuticist and you want
to read this thing closely,
it's not so straightforward
because somebody starts, somebody
finishes, so how do you determine
who gets the first word
and who gets the last word?
Why is the Arabic call to prayer
represented by a recording?
So no presence, right?
It's always done with a recording.
[ Background conversation ]
Very good, yeah.
On his own original
recordings, this is what he does.
And you know, and then you can go on
and sort of worry this as you know,
unemployed, most colleges want to do
hermeneutics, we'll have a lot read
but that's the beauty of music.
It makes possible these sorts
of call them idle you
know, speculations.
you know, it's a feel-good thing but
I think we should just sort of open
out those issues and as I say,
if one has a secure understanding
whether it's with the language,
which Martha was asking
me about or whether it's
of the rhythmic principles
that are at work,
that's the way they are, yeah.
>> All right let's thank
Kofi Agawu so much for...
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov